on the stay that free stage with a
question from nashville
is caleb hey caleb what's your question
hey uh i want to say thanks for having
me on i know you have to do this um sure
so
i hope you can give me some advice here
we'll try so uh my grandma is 72 years
old
she's debt free house and all her only
assets are her house in his 60 000
cd she recently started talking with her
high school sweetheart after 55 years
and has just gotten engaged
but the issues are we've ran three
background checks on this guy and he's
found out he's 500 000
in debt largely to the irs um other than
that we
talked to his ex-wife and says he has a
problem with over-indulging alcohol
being a very dominant male figure as
bad financial tendencies obviously yeah
um the thing is she's not listening to
any of these red flags so she hasn't
felt affection
uh since my grandfather died about 17
years ago and uh she's really flattered
by you know little gifts and stuff that
you know he's giving her and uh we we've
really tried to talk her out of this but
we just don't she's
all this stuff all the red flags just
it's not going one year out the other
with her
just because she hasn't felt affection
by a man and uh i'm just trying to see
if you have any advice for me and how we
should approach this situation before
she gets married
wow well
i want to first commend how much you
care about her because it shows that her
family cares about her
so much that y'all would go to that
effort to do the background checks and
think about her and look out for her and
even come here and ask this question so
well done you love her very much
and that shows yeah oh that's powerful
you know even as he described it he said
she's 72 yeah
and it's his grandmother's when i think
of a grandmother i think if someone like
you know that's a lot older than that my
mom's 72 dave so this would be like
you know this question my mom i'm like a
60 year old grandfather shut up chris
grandparents i think if grandparents is
older but that's my mom
i mean you know yeah yeah so uh the
uh the problem is not
how to smoke the guy out the problem is
she's not willing to do it
um i'll give you some ideas on smoking
him out uh and he'll run
he'll run when you do this uh
but you but she has to do them and so
uh because you can't you know it's not
illegal to be stupid right
that's the problem and um
[Applause]
who will she listen to pastor
another friend someone that's wise she's
not listening to her family
she's she has seven kids she's only
listening to one and uh
that one kid has
just came out with our family uh as a
homosexual and that's the only person
that she's listening to and he's the
only one
uh you know our family is very well is
he concerned about
this guy no that's the thing like we're
all he had like a big spotlight you know
we're all
conservative christians i understand but
i'm not worried about his lifestyle what
i'm concerned about is does he still
have influence with her
and is he questioning also this
relationship
he's not because he's trying to get the
spotlight uh you know
he has his approval everything no matter
the red flags um
this is like a big fan okay so he's
going along with it he's going along
with okay so he's he has influence but
he's not
helpful because he wants to go along
that's the only person that's the but
because of
the dynamic okay and um
is there anyone that she trusts that
will listen to her that's who i'm
looking for that's it that's the only
person she's not listening to pastor
she's not listening to
friends she's not listening to nobody um
we had you know
this my whole family here this weekend
for mother's day yeah and the guy showed
up
and uh it was a a big fiasco but you
know
just you know we try to talk to her and
we don't know what else to do and we're
really scared for her yeah
i'm scared for her too because i think
she's been taken um
i don't know how to stop it from
happening
because it's not illegal and uh she just
might got bad judgment that's what it
amounts to
and um and you've outlined why you think
that is and i
you know with what with what you're
telling me i you know
uh assuming all the information you have
is correct um it's a bad situation
obviously she doesn't need to go forward
on but i mean all she would have to do
is just say
uh i need a prenup before marriage i
need to put everything
um over here to the side that i
currently own that you don't have access
to
it to ensure that this relationship is
not about
uh and she could blame it on the family
right she could say so that my family
will shut up
okay maybe you talk to her about that if
anybody's having a conversation with her
that's that's
normal at normal tones without it
screeching and yelling and all this
but i mean if if whoever's having a calm
conversation
hey granny we just here's what you ought
to do blame it on me
and tell him that you need to have a
prenuptial agreement to put all of your
assets
aside so that my kids will shut up
now is there a way to where that she has
to have like a co-sign of the family
because
okay it'd still be her decision then her
decision to do it yeah or not do it
yeah if she's she's a she's an adult
she's allowed
she's allowed to conduct business and
allowed to get married and allowed to do
all this i mean
unless she has proven incompetent
mentally and you've not mentioned that
no she's not lonely is not mental
incompetence
um needing of affection is not mental
incompetence
uh so you got to go into court and prove
her like if she had alzheimer's or
something you could get her
you could get a guardian appointed to
her by the judge right and then you
would take it
take away her rights to do transaction
on her behalf because she's not capable
yeah
that's why it says this is just bad
judgment this is not any of that
what did she say did y'all present this
with her like the five hundred thousand
dollars of irs doesn't know that did
y'all
talk to her about that what did she say
she's almost like she don't even believe
it yeah
and like you know we've even hired a pi
and wow the other day the pi
even told us to because when he showed
up they said you know kidnap your mom
because this is a bad situation wow and
you know it's just like we try to talk
to her yeah well i wouldn't do that
that's a federal crime okay right right
right i'm just saying like with the
what's
an idiot but yeah uh i mean he's i guess
he's just being melodramatic but i mean
uh i might take her on a long trip
though right
a friendly type of kid hey granny we're
going to hawaii for three weeks
okay load her up uh here we go yeah
uh you know if your family has the the
if you can get her
uh out from under his influence long
enough
on a vacation a family vacation or
something but if somebody can just say
granny
listen blame it on me yeah just blame it
on me
that the kid in order for my kids to
shut up i need to do a prenup
because that'll make you sure make you
sure that this guy's real
and if you do that i'll shut up and i'll
stand with you against the rest of
family
and will shut up if you'll at least get
a prenup is it once she introduces
prenup to duber
duber's gonna run yeah okay because this
guy's after one thing
that's we all say too yeah yeah i think
he is i think i think you've identified
that
and i really don't disagree with your
conclusions on that but
wow that is so hard it's so hard
and um yeah and there's a lot of dynamic
going on in the whole family so
wow what a deal hey man thanks for
coming by thank you